il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique avec william l
bonsoir williams vous êtes avec moi ce
soir en plateau pour me parler du projet
une vitesse donc tout à fait bonsoir
fois l'or pendant une guerre chaque camp
choisi ces armes certains font le choix
de la haine et de la violence quand
d'autres choisissent l'amour et la
musique et c'est cette deuxième option
qu'on choisit des fouineurs et
anne-sophie bavent membres de
l'association à cazes
alors un petit mot sur des cahiers
meneur qui il est c'est un homme aux
multiples facettes
il a les chefs d'orchestre producteur de
musique et surtout réalisateur du projet
unités qu'est ce que c'est que le projet
unité c'est une initiative lancée par
l'association a case
ils ont un studio qui se trouve à
villepreux ils ont décidé de créer un
collectif nommé ras connexion nous
sommes allés rencontrer desvres dans son
studio qui nous a expliqué l'objectif du
projet race connexion est né du après 13
novembre
en fait je pense que comme toute
personne sensible vous avez été
bouleversé par tout ce qui s'est passé
et c'était naturel de vouloir faire
quelque chose d'irréel quelque chose à
exprimer ce que je ressentais par
rapport à un modèle de vie par rapport à
tout ce qui était construit et que des
personnes mal intentionnées veulent
détruire
donc l'idée c'était vraiment de réunir
tout un collectif d'artistes de toute la
mouvance reggae ragga dancehall et afin
d'exprimer notre notre unité pour
défendre nos valeurs
initiative moyen masque après nous en
dire un peu plus sur le collectif
bien sûr alors ce qu'on peut dire
surtout c'est que ça donne l'eau à la
bouche
ça c'est un projet qui réunit 34
chanteur huit musiciens de toute la
scène reggae ragga dance hall avec des
têtes d'affiché comme le backing band de
tiken jah fakoly colocks princess erika
ou encore brahim mais j'en passe
évidemment beaucoup d'autres alors tous
ces gens là sont rassemblés sur une
seule chanson qui s'appelle unités vous
allez me dire réunir autant de
personnalités sur un seul projet c'est
quasiment mission impossible
ils ont commencé un peu après les
attentats et ils ont mis
plusieurs semaines pour arriver à tout
enregistrer mais dave qui est musicien
avait déjà un bon carnet d adresses
pardon et quand c'est pour la bonne
cause ça va beaucoup plus vite
nous avons travaillé déjà deux au
premier cercle très restreint donc avec
mon binôme enso nous occupons de
l'association ne faut se tourner
l'association est là nous avons co écrit
les paroles et la musique est mon com'
de ce qu'un grand chanteur j'ai fait
après la une de mes amis qui l'avaient
qui je travaille auprès d'amundi qui
j'ai chanté la mélodie et puis qui a qui
là qu'il a arrangé qu'il a bien
structuré et nous avons nous avons
envoyé les markets
la maquette à tous les chanteurs donc
chacun savait exactement ce qu'il avait
à faire et les us cling cling donné il
fallait faire le montage unité c'est
donc une chanson qui rend hommage à
toutes les victimes d'attentats à
travers le monde
mais c'est surtout un message est une
réponse à l'oppression terroristes et à
leur volonté de provoquer cas aux
divisions et n
mais surtout ce qu'on ressent c'est
l'implication d'edf dans son combat
lorsqu'il nous en parle
nous sommes tous français nous aimons
voir des homos manger nous allons faire
l'amour nous avons sorti rosemont la
musique regarder la télé par notre âme
et manger ce qu'ils mangent et en grande
tradition culinaire ici au fil d'un pays
où il ya un grand métissage
on commence la musique on mange des
africains de la cuisine thaïlandaise
chinoise tout ce que vous voulez
antillaise et tout ça c'est nous tout ça
c'est nous on veut nous faire croire que
non que nous sommes le mal non c'est pas
possible on tient tout ça tout ça et est
juste quand l'outil en musique
alors cette chanson l'unité ou est-ce
qu'on peut l'écouter
alors elle est sortie le 20 avril et
pour dave et anne-sophie c'est
certainement le début
grande aventure pas la peine de dire que
tous les artistes ont collaboré
collaborer bénévolement au projet la
chanson unité elle est disponible pour
l'instant sur youtube sous le nom de
unité ras connexion elle est gratuite et
libre de droit est l'objectif du
collectif c'est qu'elle soit diffusée
un maximum tout le monde est invité à la
partager et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
vous invite à faire en vous rendant sur
youtube pour aller regardez vous même le
clip et on va se quitter en diffusant un
court extrait parce que un court extrait
vaut mieux qu'une longue chronique